des festivités à minimale demain crise
sanitaire oblige mais si l'histoire
retient la date du 8 mai 1945 c'est la
veille le 7 mai 45 et que l'allemagne
nazie à signer la capitulation sans
condition une signature qui a mis fin à
la seconde guerre mondiale c'est à reims
que les faits se sont déroulés et celle
charge avec rôle au parquet 7 mai 1945
2h41 du matin alfred jodl chef
d'état-major de la wehrmacht signé
l'acte de reddition de l'armée allemande
un événement historique qui s'est
déroulée entre les murs d'une salle de
classe d'un collège de reims eh bien on
se trouve donc dans la salle des cartes
où a été signée la capitulation nazie en
europe le 7 mai 45
ça s'est passé sur trois jours en fait
entre l'arrivée donc du premier
représentant en asie donc est arrivé le
5 mai ici à reims pour commencer à
négocier d'abord une tentative de peste
et paris l'objectif des nazis c'était
d'obtenir la paix sur le front de
l'ouest donc face aux américains et aux
anglais notamment et de pouvoir
retourner les quelques troupes qu'il
leur restait sur le front aux
soviétiques et donc ils vont tenter de
négocier pendant deux jours et l'issue
du symel vont se rendre compte qu'il
n'est pas possible d'obtenir cette paix
séparée qui sont obligés de signer une
capitulation totale de toutes les armées
allemandes sur tous les fronts et donc
c'est assez drôle à que l'acte de
capitulation va être rédigé depuis
février 1945 le général eisenhower a
emménagé son quartier général à reims
pour être au plus près de la ligne de
front
il se trouve que eisenhower avait décidé
d'aménager son quartier général
ici à reims pour des raisons
stratégiques puisque la ville était une
ville assez importante avec le coude
axes de communication et en même temps
suffisamment éloigné du front pour ne
pas mettre en danger l'état major c'est
donc en pleine nuit que l'allemagne
capitule à reims ils sont quatre
signataires le général bedell smith pour
les américains le général soit par of
côté soviétique et enfin le général se
baisse pour les français en face le
général jodl pour les allemands dans la
salle
la tension est palpable il est témoin
nous raconte que l'atmosphère était
assez irréel d'abord parce que ça se
passait en pleine nuit à 12h41 et que
cette salle avait été aménagée comme un
studio photo d'après le témoignage d'un
reporter avec beaucoup d'éclairage des
spots toute cette myriade de
journalistes qui étaient là pour
immortaliser l'instant
et il avait une tension extrêmement
forte on sait que le général jodl est
arrivé extrêmement crispé et on a une
description comme ça avait été moi qui
me dit que tous les muscles de son
visage était extrêmement tendue et la
grande urgence pour l'état major allié
c'était de faire cesser le plus
rapidement possible les opérations
militaires
et donc comme un délai de 48 heures
avait été accordée aux troupes
allemandes pour cesser les combats
il était très important de pouvoir
signer le plus tôt possible le lendemain
le 8 mai 1945 jour de cessation des
combats
une seconde cérémonie est organisée à
berlin cette fois que le lac qui était
signée donc arras le 7 mai 45 s'est fait
en grande partie à l'insu des
soviétiques qui n'ont été associés pour
la forme assez tardivement et donc
staline a jugé que cette signature la
n'était pas symboliquement assez
valorisante pour les troupes soviétiques
pouvoir évidemment que les soviétiques
avaient payé un très lourd tribut à la
guerre contre les nazis qu'il venait de
libérer
là est donc staline a souhaité que le
second acte le plus officiel de cette
capitulation soit signé le 8 mai à
l'état major du maréchal joukov
qui était donc le commandant suprême des
forces soviétiques avaient là parce
qu'il ya une autre portée symbolique à
ses yeux tous les chefs d'état major et
commandant suprême des différentes
forces alliées ont pu être présentés
permettant de se rendre à berlin alors
que à reims livré que les généraux qui
ont signé parce qu'on était encore en
plein dans les opérations étaient d'un
rang hiérarchique mans inférieur
l'histoire européenne retiendra donc
cette date 8 mai 1945
en russie le jour de la victoire est
célébrée le lendemain le 9 mai décalage
horaire oblige au moment de la signature
à berlin le 8
moscou entamé déjà son 9 mai 1945
[Musique]